[Music]
the three laws in genetics form the crux
of this topic these laws not only
answered a few questions but were even
ahead of that time they were
instrumental in proving a few important
concepts which were discovered in the
following years but do all the organisms
always follow these fundamental laws
when crossed do all organisms always
give offsprings in the ratios that
Mendel obtained not really even this has
exceptions but before we get to know the
exceptions to these laws let's first try
answering some interesting questions
that will help us understand the
concepts learn so far thoroughly to
begin with let's imagine we have this
plant with axial flowers we know that
the axial opposition trait is dominant
over the recessive trait of the terminal
flower position so this plot has the
dominant genes for the character flower
position now this is the phenotype of
the plant which is understood by a mere
glance at it but can you tell me what
the genotype of this plant is is it
homozygous or heterozygous for this
character let me simplify this for you
let's consider the alleles a and capital
to represent the dominant trait axial
position and a in lowercase for the
recessive trait terminal position so can
you tell me whether this plant has the
genotype a a or a a just a glance is not
enough it could be either now I'm going
to ask you an interesting question and I
want you to really try your best to
answer it is there any way in which you
can find the genotype here think about
it maybe a test would help can we look
at the chromosomes and say which genes
are present on them nope that's not
possible at all then what kind of a
testing method would help us
it's simple actually the only way to
know the genotype of this plant is by
crossing this with a plant whose
genotype is known to us so what plant
will we opt for in order to cross the
best choice will be a plant that is
recessive in phenotype in this case we
will opt for a plant with terminal
flowers but why should we take a plant
with a recessive trait why not dominant
because for a recessive plant it will
definitely have the alleles a a both in
lowercase this is the genotype we can be
sure about this is the unknown genotype
for us after crossing the f1 generation
we'll get one allele a written in
lowercase from this parent so we write
these a in all these four places talking
about the genotype of our plant there
could be two possibilities one it could
be a a both capital or it could be a a
one in capital and the other in
lowercase these are the two
possibilities or cases now let's look at
case one on crossing in the f1
generation we obtain all the plants
which have axial opposition's this means
all the plants will be heterozygous with
one capital A and one lowercase a now we
move on to case 2 look at the plants
obtained in the f1 generation we get two
axial and two terminal they are in the
ratio one to one so what can we deduce
from these two cases simple we can guess
the unknown genotype by looking at the
results in the f1 generation if we cross
a plant with the plant having a
recessive phenotype and we get all the
plants with flowers in the axial
position then the genotype of our plant
will be a both in capital and if we get
plants with dominant and recessive
traits in the ratio one to one then the
genotype of our plant will be
aa1 in capital and the other in
lowercase so wasn't this interesting we
used another plant to find the genotype
of a plant this type of a cross is
referred to as a test cross it's a cross
where the individuals i gossiped ii is
found as i gossiped ii simply means the
homozygous or the heterozygous nature
it's found by crossing it with a
recessive individual test crosses are
the most powerful tools used in several
experiments let's try to solve another
question in the next part phenotype and
genotype are the important concepts
which we know pretty well now can you
tell me how many phenotypes are obtained
on crossing a homozygous plant having
round and yellow seeds with another
homozygous plant having wrinkled and
green seeds we want the number of
phenotypes and not the ratio let's crack
this together
the first thing we need to note is that
we are looking at two characters seed
shape and seed color we are crossing
this plant with the one having wrinkled
and green seeds so isn't this a dihybrid
cross yes it is now let's get to the
next step we are supposed to calculate
the number of phenotypes obtained on
crossing these the f1 generation as we
know will always have all the dominant
characters expressed this is because the
f1 hybrids are all heterozygous in
nature so there's just one phenotype of
the f1 generation that is round and
yellow in this case what about the
number of phenotypes in the f2
generation if you remember the table of
any dihybrid cross we obtain the
phenotypic ratio 9 2 3 2 3 2 1 take a
moment to go through the Sables that
we've seen previously
what would be the number of phenotypes
in the f2 generation as there are four
different varieties of plants we can say
that there are four phenotypes you
should know that a dihybrid cross always
gives us four different phenotypes in
the f2 generation now let's make it a
bit more interesting can you tell me
what's the genotypic ratio obtained in
the f2 generation after a dihybrid cross
nine two three two three two one is the
phenotypic ratio you can pause the video
and try finding the genotypic ratio of
these offsprings
the answer is tricky the genotypic ratio
obtained for the f2 generation is this
huge isn't it why is it so big it's
because there are nine different
genotypes according to the table study
of genetics is indeed very interesting
now can you answer one more question
that Nora has for you she wants to know
which cross our crosses explained the
law of independent assortment think
about the law first
it states that genes for different
traits can segregate independently
during gamete formation now if we
consider a monohybrid cross then the
event of assortment of genes is ruled
out as there's only one pair considered
at a time however when there are two or
more genes involved as we can see in
this case the dominant and the recessive
alleles of the different genes a thought
independent of each other that is the
reason why we get four different
combinations at the end does this law is
best understood when we study dihybrid
or higher crosses which involve more
characters D is the best answer we have
been talking about dihybrid crosses and
dihybrid ratios since quite some time
now let's try cracking just one simple
question related to a tri hybrid cross
in the next part
we have been talking about monohybrid
and dihybrid crosses for quite a while
now let's try answering a question
related to try hybrid cross it's very
simple so let's say we consider the
three characters like the height of the
plant seed shape and seed color all
being Gino typically heterozygous now
can you guess how many possibilities or
combinations of gametes will be formed
from these will there be four
possibilities or six or eight
combinations you can pause the video and
make the necessary calculations on a
paper we get a two possibilities when a
heterozygous individual for all the
three traits is considered the simple
trick is by using the formula to raise
to n here n is the number of characters
considered at a time now since this is a
tri hybrid cross the formula will be 2
to the power 3 which gives us 8 so there
are 8 possible combinations of gametes
that are obtained now to take it a step
ahead can you tell me the different
combinations of genes in these eight
gametes let's solve this together the
genotype of this parent is TT rry why
all letters written in one upper and one
lower case to represent heterozygous
genotype to get the gametes we take the
help of the law of independent
assortment according to the law Thea
leaves four different genes will a sort
independent of each other so in simple
words the alleles T and T will assualt
independent of the other alleles are an
R and even Y and Y that means the T can
be assorted with either R or R and
similarly with either Y or Y there is a
simple way to find the combinations we
write the letters capital T and
lowercase T four times each
why do we write it four times that's
because we know that each allele has the
possibility of a sorting with all the
remaining four alleles so we write the
letters T and T like this now the second
set of genes can be assorted in an
alternate fashion written twice so we
write capital R here and here followed
by our in lowercase twice we repeat the
same procedure with the T allele written
in lowercase
now comes the last allele set any idea
how will this be assorted well it's
quite simple the last set will be
written in single alternate fashion that
is why in capital followed by Y in
lowercase this has done one after the
other to find all the gametes so a total
of eight gametes or combinations to be
precise are obtained in an individual
that is heterozygous for all the three
traits now let me ask you an extremely
interesting question if we cross a plant
having a red flowers with a plant having
white colored flowers then is there a
possibility to obtain an intermediate
flower color like pink at the first
instance you may say no most of us would
think that the plants in the f1
generation can either be red or white
depending upon the dominant trait but
what if I tell you that there are
certain exceptional plants which show
this interesting characteristics want to
know more about these exceptions for
that we will have to understand the
exceptions to Mendelian inheritance I'll
see you in the next part
[Music]